we humans are unable to experience the
true nature of the universe unfiltered
our senses and brains can only process a
fraction of the world so we have to use
concepts and tools to learn about the
true nature of reality technological
progress not only widened our knowledge
about the universe it also made us aware
of the unsettling possibilities in the
future it might become possible to
simulate entire universes but if this is
an option how can we know that it's not
already happened what if we are not
creators but creations is it possible
that we are not real and we don't even
know it
[Music]
if our current understanding of physics
is correct then it's impossible to
simulate the whole universe with its
trillions and trillions of things but we
don't actually need to anyway we only
need enough universe to fool the
inhabitants of our simulation into
thinking that they're real
who needs billions of galaxies we only
need the space our subjects are allowed
to explore just be a flat projection and
they would have no way to know what
about small things like cells or
bacteria we don't really need them when
you use a microscope what you see could
be instantly created same with atoms the
chair you're sitting on right now does
not need to be simulated with
quadrillions of atoms we just need the
outermost layer of it it might be empty
inside until you decide to break it open
your body might feel like it's filled
with bubbly things but it might be empty
until you open it the minimum
requirement for our simulation is only
the consciousness of our virtual humans
our subjects just need to think the
simulation is real okay
so are we being simulated well maybe but
there are a few conditions that need to
be met obviously we have no authority
over this topic so please take
everything we say with a grain of salt
based on a modified version of the
original simulation argument by Nick
Bostrom we have five assumptions for you
if they're true you dear viewer are
living in a simulation assumption one
it's possible to simulate consciousness
nobody knows what consciousness is for
the sake of argument let's assume that
you could generate consciousness by
simulating a brain brains are pretty
complex if you count every interaction
between synapses as one operation your
brain runs at about 10 to the power of
17 for 100 million billion operations
per second
let's generously assume we need 10 to
the power of 20 operations to simulate
one second of human consciousness but we
don't want to simulate just one human we
want to simulate all of human history at
once so we can skip around let's say we
want to simulate 200 billion humans with
an average lifespan of 50 years one year
has 30 million seconds times 50 years
times 200 billion humans times 10 to the
power of 20 operations so we need a
computer able to handle a million
trillion trillion trillion operations
per second more operations than there
are stars in the observable universe a
computer like this is just impossible
except maybe it isn't assumption to
technological progress will not stop
anytime soon if we assume that
technological progress continues in a
similar fashion as it has so far
then there might be galaxy spanning
civilizations with unlimited computer
power at some point beings on a
technology level so advanced that we
could barely distinguish them from God's
a computer that can handle a million
trillion trillion trillion operations is
serious business but there are actually
concepts for computers which could
handle this the matryoshka brain is the
theoretical mega structure made up of
billions of parts orbiting a star
feeding on its radiation a computer of
this scale would have enough power to
simulate many thousands if not millions
of humanity's at the same time
under technologies like high-end future
quantum computers might lower the size
drastically so it might be possible to
do this with a structure the size of a
large city or even smaller but only if
there's still someone around to build
the computer assumption 3 advanced
civilizations don't destroy themselves
if there is a point at which all
civilizations destroyed themselves this
whole discussion ends here looking into
space you'd expect a universe filled
with millions of alien civilizations but
we see nobody the reason for this might
be great filters great filters are
barriers life has to overcome like
nuclear war asteroids climate change or
a black hole generator if life is
inherently self-destructive then there
are no simulations we explain this in
more detail in our Fermi paradox video
assumption for super advanced
civilizations want to run simulations
when we speak of posthuman civilizations
we don't know what we're dealing with to
think we know what beings as powerful as
gods want is pretty arrogant imagine the
smartest ant on earth living next to an
amusement park it's curious about what
humans are up to so you try to explain
unfortunately the ant just doesn't
understand the concept of rollercoasters
and standing in lines and holidays and
fun doesn't make sense to an ant living
an ant life it's the same with us and a
post human being compared to them
we are ants running simulations for fun
or science might be an absurdly stupid
idea to them but if they do want to run
simulations for whatever reasons and
assumptions one two three are true -
then the chances are not zero that you
are living inside a simulation
assumption 5 if there are a lot of
simulations you are probably inside a
simulation
if there are simulated civilizations
it's likely that there are a lot of them
after all we assume that post human
beings have access to practically
unlimited computing power so if they run
simulations it would be convenient to
run millions or even billions of them if
there are billions of simulated
universes there are probably trillions
and trillions of simulated conscious
beings which would mean that the vast
majority of all conscious beings that
will ever have existed are simulated so
for every conscious being made of flesh
a billion simulated ones exists since we
have no way of knowing if we are
simulated or not in this case the
chances of you being one of the nine
hundred ninety nine million 999,999
simulated ones are pretty high so what
you consider reality might not be real
at all you really might be simulated all
of this is based on a lot of assumptions
that we can't really test right now
so many scientists disagree with this
whole thought experiment so don't burn
your house down to test if there will be
glitches if you are simulated not that
much changes for you you might be on a
small planet speeding through eternal
nothingness or a simulation inside a
computer your existence does not become
more or less scary and bizarre all we
can hope to do is try to live good lives
and have a good time and hope that if we
actually are simulations in a
supercomputer nobody trips over the
power cable
oh oh oh no I think I just unplugged the
simulation but what if that doesn't
matter what if we are in one right now
what if you are simulated Jake over at
Lisa's 3 is looking into that click here
to watch his video and subscribe to his
channel why are you still here
go over to vsauce3 watch the video and
subscribe we promise it's worth your
time